gymnastics is such a mental sport as
much as it is physical and so I think
that by having confidence in being
prepared I think that's you know the
most important thing that you can do to
try and help yourself your body is doing
the gymnastics almost on muscle memory
it's almost like you just flip the
switch in your body's doing these
routines and so I think the process of
you know the team not only consisting of
five girls instead of six is it's hard
to grasp because you know it used to be
in 96 the Magnificent Seven and everyone
remembers that and then it dropped down
to six people and now it's at five so it
really is putting a puzzle together and
I think we make it look so easy but it
really isn't you know it's it's so
grueling and you know it's not just
about leotards and scrunchies in your
hair and glitter on your eyes it's like
I guess i would say hardest sports just
because it takes it takes everything you
got you know it's you have to be so
disciplined on an aspect of not just in
training but you're outside life and in
our gym now we have like playback so we
have like huge monitors by the balance
being the bars the vault and tumbling
and it's actually really cool because
there's a camera set up that shoots two
different angles so you actually can
perform your skill and then you know you
get off the bar and you can look up at
the screen to be able to actually see
that instantaneously of course your
coach can tell you what to do but I feel
like it's really helped a lot of
gymnasts because they can look back and
they can make these Corrections almost
instantly because they really can feel
it by watching it you know there's so
much attention on gymnastics every four
years when the Olympics are here and
while we do appreciate you know that
that media attention and everything that
comes with the Olympic Games I think you
know so many people really underestimate
how much hard work actually goes